also back with me tonight britt hume
foxnews senior political analyst prick
good to see you this evening you say
that that with each pass hi there with
each passing day the argument for this
lockdown this nationwide lockdown gets
weaker and weaker what do you mean by
that
two things martha first the collateral
damage from it is extraordinary i mean
we started this process you may recall
the social distancing followed by the
you know the full lockdown almost
international quarantine to protect our
medical system from being overwhelmed
what's happening to our medical system
now is that hospitals are failing across
the country many are closing
I noticed the Mayo Clinic yesterday had
a big set of layoffs the damage to our
medical our health care system it seems
to me it's something we really have to
take into account here it's very serious
that's just one example the economic
damage of course has been widely
discussed the budgetary harm is you know
beyond belief I mean we're selling our
country and our and our and future
generations with debt on a scale it was
already high now it is far far worse not
to mention you know the toll on
businesses which won't reopen and so on
the unemployment the consequences for
children of being locked up at home and
not being able to go to school with
their friends and be outside mental
health issues that arise from that the
domestic violence that you heard
referred to by earlier guests and so
that's that's part of it to damage from
it the second thing I'd say about it is
that we basically there are basically
two points about this from from what I
think is a health point of view this is
a this is a disease that overwhelmingly
of affects elderly people and those with
serious underlying medical conditions
everyone else is much less vulnerable
down to children who seem almost totally
invulnerable to catching the disease so
that is that is an issue and that is an
issue that can be addressed can be we
can protect elderly people by by having
them be quarantined we also have to do
you know we the fact that they're
they're so vulnerable has been proven by
the outbreaks that have occurred in
nursing homes so there is that and
secondly of course is the fact that if
you look at what this tragic situation
in the new
York metropolitan area has really not
been replicated anywhere else around the
country and least of all in states like
you know North Dakota from whom whose
governor you just interviewed it's just
not happening and you know this it this
is not in my view all about simply we
were so good at the mitigation efforts I
think there's reason to believe that
this disease turned out outside of
certain populations not to be nearly as
severe and dangerous as we thought
and certainly the death rates I think
we'll end up reflecting that I mean we
saw that in Italy as well there were
pockets areas in the Lombardy district
that got hit very very hard and then
there were other areas that were hit
much less and still continue to be hit
in much much lower numbers I just want
to ask you because I know you were
intrigued as I was by this piece that
Heather McDonald wrote about the impact
of the fear factor of this and she talks
about people jogging and running in
Central Park in the middle of New York
City which I have done many many times
myself with masks on and this notion
that you know that being outside doesn't
dissipate this virus that's sort of you
know and I wonder how long it's going to
take for us to start to let go of some
of that fear that's been so deeply
driven in by the coverage in many ways
of this of this virus spread you're
you're absolutely right about that Marth
and I think what we've what we've
succeeded in doing and this was
principally because of the of the models
of the disease's progress that that the
your previous guest has provided which
have turned out in case after case to be
wildly off and particularly the original
model from the Imperial College in
London which was so extravagantly
off-base it scared the daylights out of
everybody and I think that doctors ouchy
and Burks were content to sort of let
that happen because I think they were
afraid that people wouldn't socially
distance if people wouldn't take engage
in the mitigation efforts that they can
take right and the result is we we have
a terrified population and we have
people you know wearing masks while out
jogging in Central Park seems to me to
be almost a form of insanity I mean
everything we've we've told about this
has been told about this disease is it
doesn't do well outdoors in open air and
yet people are wearing masks while
jogging so
I think Heather MacDonald's concern
about fear is well-placed yeah Brett
thank you always good to see you sir
thanks for coming in tonight thank you